all right let's move over to uh
to this man right here to joe rogan we
have a few tidbits
on on joe rogan so i figured let's do
this whole segment here about rogan so
we're gonna have to go back and forth
uh this is uh you sent this to me this
is joe rogan on chappelle's news special
if even further and the best evidence is
dave chappelle
yeah dave chappelle's recent sticks and
stones netflix documentary
for whatever reason rotten tomatoes
thought it would be a good idea to only
have it reviewed by
i want to point out that i am pausing
this and using under copyright law fair
use as we are providing
uh transformative commentary to these
clips i would still wait to cover the
other thing
tomorrow maybe do you think so safe just
to be safe
why because we're playing this because
we're playing this and then we want to
do the other thing and
they may not get us to the other thing
all right but you know what i'm gonna do
i'd rather do the other thing then
i'm just i'm i'm just being cautious we
could we can do
whatever we want to do [ __ ] are you so
now now but we're not going to do stuff
because of [ __ ] face now
i'm not saying not to do it i'm just
raising
an issue now so it's not an issue later
but
i don't know what these people are gonna
do anymore
all right you know what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna do this one i'll do the other one
but when i cut them i'll keep them
separate okay there we go
it's gonna be two segments five we'll
find out super progressive critics
only critics they closed it off to the
public
it got zero percent on rotten tomatoes
they then
opened it to the pub i see what you're
doing you get it okay public
and it got 99
of course if that doesn't show a crazy
disparity
between first of all the idea that
you're gonna suppress it
like you're gonna say it's zero percent
so no one's gonna watch it and we're
gonna shut dave chappelle down
he's canceled can you imagine somebody
suppressing information it's disgusting
can you i'm with you are you with him
one of the worst things you could do
really
should uh silence critics we're we're
with we're with him right
we're with him right now like trying to
tell people hey man you know you can't
you can't talk about that dude
yeah that's not cool that's not cool bro
people say a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] about
me i don't try to
say yeah yeah just man but i just i
don't suppress it
we're with you joe yeah we're with you
dude we're we're with him
but people love him you can't cancel
someone who doesn't care man well you
can't cancel dave chappelle no you can't
but on top of that like
th how would they not understand that
someone
is going to know that you're not opening
it up to the public
and that once it does get open to the
public you're going to get a massive
whiplash a backlash where people going
to come and even if they didn't want to
vote on it now they do
yeah and now they're going to give it
100 right it's almost like i'm going to
throw a hypothetical out there mike it's
almost like if there was like a clip
you know and probably nobody would have
noticed that clip if it would have just
let it run its cycle
you know uh bought somebody yeah i
wouldn't imagine
anybody ever doing a thing like that
right and then but then when you go and
you try to suppress that clip
more people you know what happens mike i
don't know if you know this more people
want to see that clip well especially
when on top of that
uh you also take down the entire full
episode of the show
that the clip came from that would be
quick but he's not for that
because that's the same thing you start
no you don't suppress information you
don't suppress it
just said it with his own words yes good
good good
or 99 i knew i had to watch it when i
saw
how all the media channel many of the
media channels that i really dislike and
do not respect
were coming so hard at it and saying oh
no you don't need to watch it and all
this i was like oh this means i
absolutely
have to watch it the guardian game the
uk gave it one star well and i wasn't
disappointed the influence of
a small group of a relatively small
group of human beings
that are in charge of these media
conglomerates
ah i'm gonna
i'm gonna have another one yeah let me
have myself my water too actually
go on ah you were saying go go on joe
is it's really astounding and
that they it's not just opinion
right it's like they're they're trying
to get people to behave
and think the way they do it's not just
yes it is activism
and yeah that's one word for it
i there's other words all i'm going to
say is there's other words that can be
used for it am i correct
other words we can't use those words
though it's not activism it
it by the way i'll help you out it ends
with ism
and it's it's also colonialism guys
what were you thinking yeah you're
[ __ ] idiots yeah
he wasn't gonna say what mike what
i wasn't though we weren't gonna say
that so you can't be mad
it's undiscovered you're right you're
right
is that okay do we do a good job black
cube they're glowing they're happy
so tell alex jones we said uh we're
doing his bidding for him
so sick of these people yeah eyes
activism
it's very transparent activism it's
opposed to
journalism i really wish there was a
place
where we could go where we can get 100
unbiased information and news yeah joe
me too me too wouldn't that be great if
we could do that joe
but i just want to play that part of the
clip because it really sets up what
joe's about right
it really sets up hey mike you know what
i was going to do
i wanted to uh i wanted to check out one
of my
one of my favorite shows um
we've played it on here before the king
and the sting
yeah brandon shaw has just continued to
remember the king and the sting
this man continues to deliver i think
some really good uh
top-notch comedy now i'm not going to
play the video yeah me and royce had a
nice little talk before the show
and i think we both agreed paste this
very well
and there's a reason why we're not going
to play the video
um it's a reason why you could only find
the video at fly height
like there's a reason for that right um
you want me to read the title of the
video or just play it uh let's just play
the
let's look people it's only nine seconds
yeah it's brendan child
and we're i want to get just
transformative commentary here guys
listen i know some bald [ __ ] dudes
are slanging dick out there
look at dana white rogan
so you know and that's the face he's
making
that is the face we didn't want to play
the video
and we wanted to play a very short
snippet of the audio
because people have been getting struck
down that's correct
left and right for this video clip
people have been playing it saying z was
taken down
because of sansi uh he didn't get struck
but he got
blocked world worldwide block uh a
couple other channels got worldwide
blocks
um but we figure we'll play snippet of
the audio we'll show his face of
realization after the fact
uh so basically what has happened is
brendan schaub has
accidentally his big fat mouth outed
rogue and is cheating on his wife
and the story is that he's not thrilled
now
the fighter and the kid or which one is
this one the king in the sting the
fighter
king of this thing the the big and the
wick it's not the show
i'm sure of that the hag i don't know
but oh that was the theophant one with
him right but the
uh he he came and he let that slip out
it was on the uh on that website uh on
their show
the episode it actually was the fighter
and the kid
i think no no no i was just trust me i
was just looking at it all right well it
was on
king in the station whichever episode it
was
has been taken down instead all right
was taken down from youtube the
audio only podcast was taken down and it
was re-uploaded but with that snippet
out
of it really yeah and the fighter and
the kid the reason i keep thinking it's
fighter in the case because the fighter
and the kid subreddit is the one that's
like
frothing at the mouth over this
fighter and the kid subreddit is the one
here it is yeah epic says king and the
sting episode 35
missing from this week dicey dicey so
these you know so they took that snippet
out of the they re-uploaded the audio
took the snippet out
and the autists are starting to figure
it out so uh
would you like to know who took down
sansy's video
i bet you i could guess but go ahead uh
it's a company called bent pixels
bent pixels aren't those the same people
that took down the base frequency
documentary because the production
company
joe rogan's project and people it's
actually not true it is joe rogan
holds a large financial stake in that
company just like on it's not his
company
on it's also part of his company he owns
a huge financial stake in it
to sit there and pretend that he's not
benefiting or he's not part of the
structure of these companies you're
lying to yourself
uh now here's the thing with ben pixels
i've been hit
before with just like you know we've
been hit as a show which is hey we're
gonna monetize your video because we
played that's fine whatever i don't care
monetize the video i think it's stupid i
still think we should be allowed to do
it but it's not worth fighting it right
um however
when they when joe mister and we just
heard his own words
we're not putting words in his mouth mr
can you imagine like suppressing
criticism
of something man like can you imagine
dude i can imagine it like suppressing
it yes joe i can imagine it well that's
what you're doing
you're doing it right now again i don't
have to imagine it right because you're
doing it right in front of me
so the episode is this is the equivalent
of joe rogan coming out pulling his dick
out and being like
bro could you imagine somebody jerking
off right in front of you could you
imagine that [ __ ]
could you imagine like yeah you're doing
it i don't have to you're just
watching you do it right now can i leave
louie
you turn around and know louis c.k is on
the other side of you in front of the
door
god damn it listen man we're going to
watch you jerk off he's going to let me
have a [ __ ] show again
no i really got to promote this thing
now you just can't sleeve so
no i'm just going to [ __ ] play with
my [ __ ]
prick [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
um so he you sent me this now
it's from our pal andy's random edits
now
this was um brennan schaub
uh rogan again recently this is after
the incident i'm not sure i think it's
after the incident but even
on that but it's still even if it's
before the incident it shows you a
how would they say it on like on law
order a pattern of behavior
a pattern of behavior but i do think
this is after the
answer this is after the incident okay
let's check it out
instead all right what it's about just
hit me back right
dominic cruz well i don't want to say
that i can't say what he
said i'll show you you want to see who
yes you get [ __ ] brandon
is it racist no no no no dominic's not
racist at all
no okay yeah yeah show that to brendan
but tell him to shut the [ __ ] up about
don't say it on your podcast don't
say this on your podcast so
how was eddie bravo so coherent nonsense
is saying it was a day or two after
okay so what's the day or two after that
man
okay that's funny andy's running a
minute he put the curb music in it
[Music]
so um and honestly get to his credit
we're gonna sit here and just [ __ ] on
joe rogan the whole time he's actually
being kind of cool about it yeah he's
like he's breaking boys yeah he's
telling me
now look like like he still has them on
it's whatever but
uh i'll say this listen i don't think
there's
a man or woman alive that didn't think
that joe rogan
isn't banging other chicks i think we
all know and according to
you know a couple people maybe some
dudes in leather
but according to our uh our washington
state correspondent owen benjamin
yes thank you he's part of the rotc news
desk he is
uh he won't wear a tie we keep telling
him to and he just won't yeah we're
going to go live to ellen benjamin and
get clark
we're watching how is it out there owen
uh guys joe rogan
looks like a toe i'm objectively not on
speed but what about the shooting
um so again
we're talking about the software but do
you think joe's starting to regret
giving helping this brendan chow guy out
well i said this earlier in the uh
when we were off the air but you know
brenton schaub reminds me of
uh what's his face steve buscemi's
character in the sopranos
he's like tony blundetto it's like tony
soprano feels this like
loyalty to his cousin and he wants to
help him out and he feels guilty but
it's like
he was just a perpetual fuck-up and he
made
all basically all of the drama that came
in seasons five and six of the sopranos
came from stupid steve buscemi's
character
and him acting out of pocket and i think
brendan schaub
he is he's the [ __ ] he's the [ __ ] of
the group he's the [ __ ] he's the tony
blendetto of the death squad like he's
just the one that's like
i'm stupid right that or the paulie
walnuts because paulie was kind of
stupid too and would always
tell people [ __ ] so
what has been happening we mentioned
earlier is that bent pixels has been
taking down
anybody that has this clip that's
playing the clip i know it's it's
happened to a couple people that i know
it's probably uh happened to either
other people that we don't know so
they're trying to make the clip
disappear however it's already out there
now more the truth of the matter is
i saw this clip uh when saying i think i
saw it on cnc when he put it out i saw
this clip
um of brendan saying it and i laughed
whatever but to be honest with you mike
i wasn't going to bring it to the show
because i'm like so what he says i don't
care
he slipped up but the moment i heard
that they were deleting it i'm like now
we have to talk about it now we have to
it wasn't a story it was a streisant
effect now it wasn't a story we knew
about it we're like who
cares doesn't get their dick wet yeah
exactly it was a non-story
and then today when i went yeah did you
know he's striking channels like royce
is like
well [ __ ] now we got a story it was like
now we've revisited it
it was like what he's doing what now no
no the cheating
gives the [ __ ] this is the story and
it's like you're using your
you're doing the thing you're doing the
thing and
so they're going around and then they're
popping and by the way i'll say this
again
nobody thinks nobody thinks that i don't
think anybody in their right mind
thought rogan isn't [ __ ] chicks i'm
actually
under the belief i'd be disappointed if
he was i know i'm under the belief that
his wife knows it i believe when you
reach that level there's an arrangement
it's like hey just [ __ ] use
protection
i don't care you know i'm living a good
life
but there's also the brendan's an idiot
because
there's just weird like respect level
right where you don't
publicly go yeah i'm [ __ ] this chick
and you make you embarrass your wife you
know it's
so nobody thought that i'm sure that
they haven't right fine that's
so that that's not what blew my mind you
know rogan's cheating on his wife yet uh
right like there's a lot of people like
you know that people have arrangements
that's fine you know everybody's happy
and then even if
you know you could even say even state
like people like you know having a right
because they're staying together for the
kids
at least they're staying together for
the k you know what i mean at least the
kids are going to have to
so whatever we don't know what anybody's
life is right i don't give a [ __ ]
and again that's why we weren't going to
cover it right we really weren't it's
not
it really weren't we weren't we were
like who cares like who cares people
getting a dick sucked in our business
people censoring content creators for
pointing something out
is our [ __ ] business that's the boys
will be our business so joe just so you
know
you're cheating on your wife is not the
problem here bud nobody cares
you not letting people you can't you
we've learned this joe rogan can't be in
the barrel
he'll make fun of other people he'll put
other people in the barrel when it's his
turn and it happens to all we've been in
the barrel
right you know who actually does the uh
shout out you know
obviously the red bar uh i don't know if
the video clips up anymore but mike
david like last year the year before
he did a really extensive
breakdown of a video of rogan being on
kill tony
and because mike's brilliant at pointing
out dynamics between
and he was breaking down how everyone
tiptoes
like everybody's breaking balls but
everybody kind of tiptoes around rogan
and then even the stuff that is like
playfully [ __ ] with him
you can kind of see it bugs him like
like you said he doesn't like
the joke should not ever be on him he
does not like that
and uh jeremiah watkins who's um the
funniest guy on kill tony
not even [ __ ] that's not even an
arguable arguable point
uh jeremiah watkins who's a very funny
comedian he's on the kill tony show
he does this gimmick where he's part of
the band for the kill tony show
but they're terrible and it's like three
comics playing instruments terribly but
they always have a theme like every show
they'll dress as like 40s detectives or
they'll do whatever and this episode
jeremiah watkins dressed as joe rogan
and he came out with a bald cap on and
he just had the on it shirt and he was
just doing like joe rogan's walk and was
making
all goofy stuff and rogan was like
but you could kind of see like this
right this kid like look it was
it's very weird i remember it was an old
episode of red bar where he broke it all
down he's like
look at this [ __ ] guy like they won't
they fear him he's like a mafia
you know the other thing about that too
isn't and this this is the part that is
kind of sad is that
he used to be be okay to be in the
barrel he was when he was just
scythe when he was just moon landing guy
or whatever people made fun of all the
time he played clips of them and he joke
about it
he's reached his status level now where
he can't
he can't be the dude in the barrel he he
will actively go out there mr free
speech mister we have to have a
conversation a conversation let's have a
conversation
is out there again making these these
clips go away and please don't tell me
it's not selective i don't want to hear
anybody say that ben pixels
copyright blocks everybody worldwide
they don't
sometimes there's clips here where we're
neutral about joe rogan we clip them up
there
nobody has a problem with them it's fine
it's no problem
there's even times where like you know
when you're being a little critical of
joe and it's you know whatever but it's
fine
but the moment he's embarrassed or one
or the group of people that he's because
that
his little group of people that he's
around with get embarrassed it's [ __ ]
take the video down take the video down
so now you're copyright
you're censoring content creators right
on this platform that you you yourself
have said
hey man you can't be censoring people
dude
yeah joe rogans complained about his
episodes
not getting monetized because he used to
actually play clips
of stuff on his show and he does it
anymore and then he would complain about
it like are you going to monetize
so you know it's you're doing this he
knows what's going on yeah yeah i mean
and there's other ways to go about it
even if you want it taken down
um you know the good example is when i
was doing night wave
last year i roasted this chick for no
reason other than she just had a
facebook page
right and she was like some personality
in in the like
she would interview people and stuff and
she was just kind of like
kind of so i made fun of her and i did i
roasted her and she was an obscure
person but she was a public figure
and i roasted this chick for like five
straight minutes it was hilarious
i wrote like a top ten list i just wrote
10 jokes about her that were mean
and it was up as a clip and everything
she reached out to me on twitter
and was so nice about it that i
not only did i take the clip down
without being like i
she implied that she wanted me to take
the clip down but she wasn't like take
this down like
she was so nice about it that not only
did i take the clip down but i felt like
absolute dog [ __ ] by the time i talked
to her and i was like
okay yeah i'm sorry like it was just it
was mean and it was unprovoked that it
was like
she goes look the bottom line is i'm
trying to get into singing
and i just had this person they produced
a song for me
it's i'm finally gonna put it out there
and if you google my name your video is
like the top thing and it's just you
[ __ ] on me and it's like
can you help me out and put my song out
i'd like that to be and i was like
yeah i feel bad i'm sorry right again i
took it down and it was over and it
wasn't like
wouldn't do it [ __ ] dude it was just
like yeah i'm sorry you're right i was
just picked it random wasn't very nice
to me
i don't want to [ __ ] your [ __ ] up and i
took it down he didn't want to [ __ ] her
[ __ ] up
and god bless her i'm not even saying i
know everybody's gonna be mean but it
was fun but like he just
if she had if she had reported the video
it would have been world war iii of
course yeah her videos would have had a
thousand down votes
it would have been trampled all over the
comp comment section she would have been
overwhelmed
but she handled it in a way where you're
like i was like ah
[ __ ] now i kind of feel bad and i was
like every shaq jack has his soft side
but it's like it's just being a human
being like you could be a dick
i'm on here i'll be fair hey man
you know you're gonna [ __ ] my new single
up and i'm like yeah that [ __ ] i'll be
fair though joe rogan were to contact us
and go don't do that would still do the
clip
i wouldn't i wouldn't do him a favor
like i've no need to do joe rogan or
facebook i get it
but if he again it's not reporting it
would just be
hey man could you be nice and yeah it
might fail with us it would fail because
you're horrible people
but because again this girl had i think
1500 facebook followers and was putting
out this
song that probably to be fair nobody's
ever going to hear anyway
but i don't want to dash somebody's
hopes and dreams you know what i mean
so i was like i get it i'm a dick i feel
bad joe rogan's a different scenario
but it still would have been appreciated
if he just contacted like man you can't
[ __ ] help me out man brendan's an
idiot you know i mean we're trying to
we're trying to chill out with this
whole thing and you know what maybe some
people would have
[ __ ] handled it differently but now
everybody's going to double down and
point out that you like getting dick
sucked by your brains better so this is
this is just
all you're doing is making this a bigger
story than it would have been this would
have disappeared
you know this would have just
disappeared nobody would have said
anything
i think this is the same reason ever
since that stuff came out after the tim
you know we played the clip after the uh
jack and tim pull podcast that's why
they don't go live anymore they
pre-record it and then they schedule it
and they air it
uh it's for that i mean he he he has
become this
joe rogan is is is an entire
company to himself he's a corp he's a
one-man corporation
the guy is is huge right he doesn't have
a lot of employees you know
um and and he cares which is fine you
know if you want to be one of those
dudes protect your image but you can't
be free speech guy right you can't be
like imagine suppressing information
while actively suppressing information
look i know we'll never be joe rogan
right
i know we'll never be his size or any
and that's fine speak for yourself
maybe you will i'll be guys i'm going to
be bigger than infowars
yeah that was great that was that was
great
and and he doesn't want to be he doesn't
want anyone to make fun of him and
that's fine man
but you but now that's it when you start
doing this when you start taking
copyright blocking stuff which let's see
what you do with with ours i'm really
curious to see i'm going to let you know
right now in just right in front of the
game
everything we've done is transformative
content from beginning of this clip
to the end you do it i'm going to i'm
going to appeal it and i want
so i just saw us right like seriously
and i mean as
sincerely if we you think what we did is
in fair use
[ __ ] sue us i do it do it i want to
see ben pixels come out
and have a lawsuit that way the rags
pick it up and then they go what are
these
because normies don't know about this
[ __ ] what are they suing them for
oh cause joe the more it's
this is the internet rogan you've been
here long enough it's like
quicksand the internet is quicksand
the more you fight it right the more you
try to go against it the more people to
go what's your rogan mad about
oh i like him oh i just i just listened
to his mma stuff but what do you mean
oh and then all of the sites are going
to start picking it up so why don't you
just [ __ ] be in the barrel take it
let people [ __ ] laugh
yeah and it's the internet joe you
[ __ ] [ __ ] some idiot is making their
lives worse
every hour on this platform relax
something else is gonna happen
between now and you trying to delete the
video that it all go away and nobody
will care about it right am i right like
you're right
if somebody's going to come along you
know they're going to find a
dead girl at jf's house or some other
[ __ ]
and everybody's going to just forget
about you so relax you just got your
dick sucked who cares
it's a minor sin right and the grand
scheme of thing it really is especially
if you're in the entertainment business
right it's not it's not that big of a
deal
but um you fighting it is a big deal you
now [ __ ] with other people
that's the problem you know whether you
like people or not
again you you can't be mr censorship
dude
and and again that's why i give credit
to the tim we had
we gave credit to tim paul when he knew
he was being recorded yeah and he was
like nah man i do no harm i'm not gonna
try to get anybody else taken down like
i don't
i don't do that [ __ ] and it's like oh
okay cool like good for him
and that's someone that you're not but
joe rogan is very very two-faced he's a
too
especially when it comes to protecting
him and his i hate saying this
brand when he's protecting the joe rogan
brand
yes he is he is he is absolutely
doesn't give a [ __ ] who you are joe
rogan doesn't
people say joe rogan stands up for other
youtube show no it's not man
it's everybody's competition to him
right
anybody he he doesn't want another joe
rogan he does
all these people that he platforms up
there and whatever
he doesn't want he wants he'll let them
get big as long as they know hey
you're there because of me you know
you're there you could stay there
you know well they're saying too that uh
you know people are speculating that uh
i mean because
how often does joe or jamie or these
guys have technical glitches or issues
very rare
yeah very on point isn't it kind of
convenient
that the [ __ ] twitter people asked
tim about
so why don't you give me some of the
names of some of these people and they
had [ __ ] them they saw the [ __ ] going
live
yeah what are the odds that happens at
that moment so people are saying they
were trying to set up tim poole
maybe i don't know i mean i i've had
stuff where my my broadcaster's frozen
up so i do get that or you that take
that cat moment
yeah i know what are the odds that's all
i'm saying i'm not saying it's not
possible in this part of the country
at this time of day localized in your
kitchen i'm just saying it's
a little weird uh seymour the house is
on fire
that's not you know you notice it it
didn't jamie didn't [ __ ] up while joey
diaz was off the air telling an
ass-eating story
right it happened right when they went
to tim pool and said you want us to take
these [ __ ] people out
thinking maybe they would have gotten
them on tape going yeah could you help
me out with that
tim pool would have been his [ __ ]
credibility would have tanked after that
right
it's almost like they were trying to
kill tim poole not literally not like
kill his momentum yeah his his career
he's doing van videos again
it's really hard to watch well they're
doing well he thinks maybe it'll get him
back to
tim paul doesn't do as well do you know
that tim poole doesn't do as well as
vandis owens
he wants to [ __ ] her and he's like i
know how i'll get to her i too live in a
van
i also have a snake could you imagine
that
that's youtube i live in a van and i own
a snake
and that's the difference is like a guy
lives in his van and owns a snake he's
literally like
right like he's just a mess but if a
chick who looks like that does it you'll
still [ __ ] her this is why women will
never be held at the same standard as
men
no dude your giant snake is why people
respect you
that hot chick goes like i live in a van
and i even snake you're like yeah that's
great look i'm paying for drinks oh [ __ ]
so
knock yourself out i'll pay for drinks
so seriously just
let's go back to your van you know what
i mean like it's that
it's not fair